[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Robbie is
in Austin Texas hi Robie how are you
good how are you doing Dave better than
I deserve what's
up so I have no debt on my name there
were some debt I cleared it out last
year the only thing we have is our
mortgage which currently is at
$350,000 I have a stable job I earn
around $150,000 from a job I have a wife
and two sons and I have $200,000 in a
savings account I cannot figure out if I
should invest in a real estate and then
create a passive income or are there
other better options that I should go
for I don't know if you'll like my
answer but if you filter this through
the ramsy baby steps which people have
followed to become baby steps
millionaires you would be at what we
call Baby Steps four five and six so
invest 15% of your income or saving for
the kids college and any extra money
we're going to throw at the mortgage
principal so we have found that one of
the keys to Building Wealth longterm is
to get a paid for house in the
mix and it's not one of the keys to
Building Wealth longterm is not keep a
200 or $350,000 mortgage while I go do
real estate that I learned on Tik
Tok gotcha that didn't come up that
never comes up when we interview
millionaires what always comes up is we
dump money in our 401K our Roth IR ra
and we paid off our house and I've got
800,000 bucks in my 401k and my house is
worth $600,000 and it's paid for and I'm
53 years old that's a typical
millionaire and so$ 800 and 600 is $1.4
million net worth right that's that's a
typical millionaire so we're always
going to lead you first to be debt free
which you've done congratulations great
job second to have an emergency fund at
mayy step three of 3 to 6 months of
expenses and then exactly what George
told told you four five and six is 15%
of your income which is just out of your
150 income going into
retirement uh starting kids college
funds you can do that out of your 150 as
well which leaves the 200 I'm assuming
you have other money other than just the
200 and I'm going to pay off my home as
fast as I possibly can then and uh with
you I think in your situation you're
going to have a paid for home in 2 or
three years and then you can invest even
more and you can invest in a broker
retir incredible ma' Robbie what I did
when I when I followed that a thousand
years
ago I I am I'm still Blown Away to this
day and I know the math I know compound
interest I know what it looks like but
I'm I took an old house payment and
rounded it up 500 bucks when I paid off
the house and I put that amount of money
into a separate mutual fund and how fast
that one mutual fund was a million
dollars blows me away to this day I look
back and I go that stinking that was a
breakthrough you know and so that's why
I know the math works is I actually
lived it and walked in it the key wasn't
you leveraged debt the key was you your
savings rate your income was freed up
because you didn't have any payments I
didn't pay off the house and then spend
the house payment I paid off the house
payment and took the house payment plus
some and invested that plus invested
more but that one account just not
having a house payment how fast that one
account became a million dollars in
mutual funds was blows my mind that's
amazing it's just amazing cool goal to
have you take like 3,000 bucks a month
that's $36,000 a year going in how fast
that blows up I mean you're not talking
about five six seven years it just blows
up it's crazy so yeah but we don't think
about investing three3 $4,000 a month we
don't think about that well we're trying
to do 17 things at once that's usually
our problem exactly create your free
every doll budget today the simplest way
to budget for your life